>> Mary Jane Deeb: Good
afternoon, ladies and gentleman,
and welcome to the African
Middle/East Reading Room.
I'm glad you're here.
This is the before last program
that we're going to be hosting
in this wonderful reading room.
We are moving to the Northeast
Pavilion, which is behind me,
over there, another very
beautiful reading room,
in January and in the meantime,
we have to move out from here.
So unfortunately, we will not
be hosting any more programs
for the next three months.
So you are here in a
way celebrating the last
of what has been a very,
very exciting time
in this reading room.
So we're all sad that we're
leaving but on the other hand,
it's only temporarily stopping.
We will resume our
exciting programs in January
and we would invite you
then in a new environment
but a very lovely one as well.
So I want to thank those
who have been coming
to these programs who have
been attending our series.
I want to thank my own staff who
have been absolutely diligent
until the last minute bringing
wonderful writers, thinkers,
authors, scholars to this
reading room to share with us
and with the public
outside around the nation,
around the world, the
scholarship and the thinking
that has come through
their work, that has come
through these collections
that they have used.
So it's only an au revoir.
It's not a goodbye but
it's just a short stop
until we resume again
in January.
So today we are very
fortunate to have
with us Mr. Dawit Gebremichael
Habte who is going to be talking
about his own book, his
own story, his own past
and hopefully project into
the future a returning scholar
to our reading room.
We have not had many
programs on Eritrea
and so it's very exciting to
have one today and to share
with our patrons, with our
members here at the Library
and with the rest of the world
a story which is very exciting,
very moving and a story that
is shared by most people
around the country since
we're all at one time
or another immigrants.
So to introduce the author, we
have our own Fentahun Tiruneh
who has been forever
our Ethiopian
and Eritrean specialist here
at the Library of Congress
and who has done a fantastic
job building the collections.
So with no further ado, Fentahun
will introduce our speaker.
Thank you.
>> Fentahun Tiruneh:
Thank you, Mary Jane.
Ladies and gentleman, I
welcome you to today's program.
My name is Fentahun Tiruneh
and I'm the area specialist
for the Ethiopian and
Eritrean collections.
Today I present to
you a professional man
with unique story of
his immigrant life.
Raised in a tiny village
just south of Asmara,
the capital of Eritrea, Dawit
Gebremichael Habte fled to Kenya
as a teenager and sought
asylum in the United States.
Dawit is now a father,
husband, software engineer,
and author of "Gratitude
in Low Voices: A Memoir."
This story is a record
of a saga of a young man
who faced several
turbulent events
in his immigrant life outside
of his family and country.
This story is told by
a very successful man
who withstood the
vagaries of immigrant life
in different countries
and who finally made it
to the United States
to build a family life.
His story encapsulates
the story of many of us
from the same region but the
difference is Dawit took his
time and successfully published
his adventures into a book.
Instead of trying to
detail his life story,
I'll let Dawit narrate
the rest of his adventure,
country by country
and event by event.
Dawit is featured in the
United States "USA Today,
New York Times, Associated
Press,
and Johns Hopkins
Gazette' and has written
for various Eritrean
websites and publications.
He lives in Maryland with
his wife and five children
and works for Bloomberg BNA.
Before I call on our
guest to the forum,
I'd like to make a
couple of announcements.
This event is being videotaped
for subsequent broadcast
on the Library's
webcast and other media.
There will be a formal
question and answer period
after the lecture in which
the audience is encouraged
to ask questions
and offer comments.
But please be advised that your
voice and image may be recorded
and later broadcast
as part of the event.
By participating in the
question and answer period,
you are consenting to the
Library's possible reproduction
and transmission
of your remarks.
An additional announcement is
that this forum does
not entertain questions
of political nature.
Thank you for your
understanding.
Now help me to welcome
Dawit Gebremichael Habte.
[ Applause ]
>> Dawit Gebremichael Habte:
I think I would be fairly
certain the majority
of you would love to go back to
where everybody knows your name
and actually they
are glad you came.
Cheers was one of my favorite
sitcoms when I first came
to the United States during my
high school years and the place
where not only everybody
knew my name
but I also knew everybody's
name is called Gejeret,
a small neighborhood in the
city of Eritrea in the city
of Asmara, the capital
city of Asmara.
That is an amazing place
where we all knew each
other's cousins, uncles,
and distant relatives and
we took care of each other.
So "Gratitude in Low
Voices" is a human story.
It's a universal human
story in that it's a journey
from my birthplace in
Gejeret, in Asmara to a place
where I knew and where
everything was familiar
to unknown destinations, unknown
places, unfamiliar destinations.
It's also a story of those that
I encountered along the way,
so many angels without
wings, individuals who came
to my rescue and to my
family's rescue in the form
of human beings
but nevertheless,
angels without wings.
When I narrate my story,
my story does not start
from the date that I was born
because the circumstances,
the situations that forced me
to leave home also
forced my parents,
my father to leave home.
They also put my
grandparents in situations
that are not normal,
to say the least.
So I'm forced to
go back generations
and you can imagine it doesn't
stop with my great parents.
It actually has to go back
and tell the story of Eritrea
and the people of Eritrea.
The human cost of history,
the human cost of war needs
to be told with the
right context
and with the right
perspective because at the end
of the day, context matters.
Angels without wings.
You see the gentleman, the
young man in the picture?
He is my childhood
friend, my best friend
and that's what makes sitting
here an amazing opportunity is I
could have, my fate and
some of my friends' fate
who are sitting here could have
been the same as that young man.
He perished in a war, in a war
that should not have existed,
that should not have happened.
But his story needs to be told
with the right perspective
and the story of my
grandparents, you see them,
the story of my aunt who
allowed us to live in her house
and grow, have a
normal childhood
in the middle of war zone.
The story of my aunt who
has no kids who actually has
to help my mom because my mother
has to spend half of the week
in the village to attend to,
look after the farm and work
and then come during
the weekends
to take care of her kids.
That's story has to be told
with the right perspective.
The story of my father has to
be told living in Saudi Arabia,
where he has to acquire
an Islamic name in order
to raise his kids to work
18 hours as a truck driver.
That story needs to be told
with the right perspective.
All is not gloomy.
It's not doom and gloom.
The story of Dr.
Tekie Fessehatzion,
a professor that I met
in Baltimore who ended
up becoming the father
that I never had.
His story needs to be told.
The story of my counselor
Beatrice Newell, a German,
who has nothing in common with
me and I had nothing in common
with her, but she took out of --
She went out of her way to
make sure this young immigrant
who barely spoke
English to end up going
to Johns Hopkins University,
after barely attending two years
of high school in
Silver Spring, Maryland.
Her story needs to be told,
with the right perspective
and with the right context.
The story of Mike Bloomberg, the
three-term mayor of New York,
who gave his young immigrant
an opportunity to go back
to his country to
contribute to be part
of a demobilization process of
reintegrating his country folks,
his countrymen his age.
This young man was probably age
20 to 23 who funded my project.
His story needs to be told,
who also funded the publication
of this book by preordering
10,000 copies.
His story needs to be told.
The story of Rose
Varner-Gaskins, David Rysak,
their story needs to be told
because that is American story.
That's not really
broadcasted in the mainstream.
Their story needs to be told
because it's a human story.
The commonalities that I found
between me and the individuals
that I encountered
are just we happened
to be decent human beings.
We decided to see what
is best in each other.
So that's why I referred
them in my book,
"Gratitude in Low Voices"
as "angels without wings."
And Robin Farrell Edmunds
of "Forward Review,"
he actually got it right.
This is what he wrote.
"This book is a reaffirmation
of the good that people can do
and how one young man succeeded
despite the odds against him."
The focus is on the people
because that gentleman has
to do whatever he did for
his own good but those angels
without wings actually did
it for no other reason except
because they see a delight in
seeing somebody else succeed,
somebody else being
happy, to say the least.
The African-American author,
writer and critic James
Baldwin had this to say.
"People are trapped in history
and history is trapped in them."
At the beginning, I said
my story does not start
with my birthday.
My journey might have started
from the place that I was born
but my story does not start
from the day that I was born.
In 1915, John Foster Dulles,
one of the highly
renowned US ambassadors,
had this to say in New York.
"From the point of view
of justice, the opinions
of the Eritrean people
must receive consideration.
Nevertheless, the strategic
interest of the United States
in the Red Sea basin and the
considerations of security
and world peace make it
necessary that the country has
to be linked with
our ally Ethiopia."
Twelve years later, Eritrea was
forcefully annexed by Ethiopia .
Guess what?
Five more years later,
half a million
of Eritreans became
refuges in Sudan.
That, by the way, is a
third of the population.
So when we talk about history,
we completely forget the
human cost of history.
We talk about war.
We talk about casualties.
We talk about collateral damage.
We dehumanize the human because
that's much easier for us
to read and have
our [inaudible].
And my objective, one of
my objectives in "Gratitude
in Low Voices" is to
awaken our consciousness.
History does eat people,
especially Eritrean history.
When 53 countries in Africa
were granted their independence
in the 1960s, Eritrea
was the only one,
Eritreans were the only ones
that were not granted
that opportunity.
And guess what?
That's supposed to
be in considerations
for security and world peace.
Isn't that oxymoron?
We will secure peace by putting
the lives of others in danger.
And to someone, this
might be a correlation
but this is more
than correlation.
This is a causation.
This is a cause and effect
because Eritreans were not given
that right to determine
their fate.
They have become refugees
and they are stranded all
over the world till this day.
So that's why when I said my
story does not from the date
of my birth because
the circumstances
that defined my fate
go much deeper.
So I spent ten years to write
a memoire and I spend most
of the time, maybe
seven to eight years,
doing research on Eritrea.
The African proverb goes, "Until
the story of the hunt is told
by the lion, the tale
of the hunt will always
glorify the hunter."
Case in point.
The story of Eritreans, you
don't find it in many places
because it was intentionally
avoided
because the other
side was glorified.
And again, I'm extremely
grateful to Mr. Mike Bloomberg
for his endorsement
when he wrote
"A candid inspiring
memoire of cultural
and historical importance."
We have to be candid even
when it comes to history.
We have to reconcile with
our own history, the bad,
the good and the ugly.
And I have tried in
"Gratitude in Low Voices"
to present an accurate
and properly referenced
historical material.
One thing that you'll find
in "Gratitude in Low Voices"
that you don't find in any other
memoire is this book has more
than 46 actual documented
references
because when historical
events is presented,
especially in a type of
memoire, our references have
to be properly documented.
So I have gone out of my way.
I spent more than two years
to make sure my claims
are properly documented.
Well, to summarize, "Gratitude
in Low Voices" is
an Eritrean story.
It is the story of Eritrea
and the people of Eritrea.
As one of the reviewers in
Eritrea accurately described,
she said, "Gratitude
in Low Voices" is a
memoire of a society."
"Gratitude in Low Voices"
is an American story.
I can't say much about other
places that I have never been
but what I witnessed
in the society
in this country is Americans
are as decent as you could get,
at a human level, at
the personal level
and that story needs to be told.
That's why I believe this
book an American story.
At the end of the day,
though, most of all,
"Gratitude in Low Voices"
is a universal human story.
Thank you so much.
[ Applause ]
>> Fentahun Tiruneh: Do you
have any comments or questions?
>> Thank you very much
for giving us the
[inaudible] of your book.
And I know that we're all
excited to read the book itself.
But I have a question.
In terms of structure, of
organization, how did you,
how did you organize
your source?
Was it in phases?
Was it chronologically?
Was it in different
experiences at different times?
How did you organize
your material?
>> Dawit Gebremichael Habte:
The advantage I have is
that by training,
I'm a biophysicist.
I have a biophysics degree.
So I was trained
how to do research.
By profession, I'm
a software engineer.
So I'm trained how
to think in blocks
because it has been [inaudible]
and for better or worse,
by necessity I became a writer
because that story
needs to be told.
So the organization
is chronological
but the challenge you
find with chronological,
with telling a story
chronologically is
and you are trying to provide
a context, you have to know
where to put that context
because if the historical
reference becomes a bit too far,
then you might lose
your audience.
So you have to try to bring
it as much as possible.
And no matter how tempting it
is to try to bring information
to the book, you have to find
a way to tie it to your story.
So it was extremely,
extremely challenging
and I'm extremely
grateful for the editors
of the [inaudible] books in
that we spent close to a year
and a half trying to get
that organization right.
Give you case in point.
It's easier to start
with the date of my birth
but fortunately it's
my great grandmother
who gave me the name.
So to me, that's a
good link to go back
in terms of family history.
And then I come to the late
'80s, '89, that's when I had
to leave Eritrea because I was
drafted into the Ethiopian army.
So that is also the perfect
place to bring the close
of the war and to
try to give context.
So it was extremely challenging
but eventually it
becomes gratifying
because the proper
contexts were able
to put it in the right place.
But the simple answer is it's
a chronological starting --
Actually the title of the first
chapter is "What is in a Name"
because there was a
great deal of squabble
when my great grandmother
was giving me my name.
Now that gives me an
opportunity because in Eritrea,
you cannot give a name, same
name as your family member
who is still alive because I had
a cousin who's name is Dawit.
So that gives me
an opportunity now
to explore the cultural
aspect of the society.
Yes, sir?
>> I was wondering if
[inaudible] whether you wrote it
in your Native language and how
you arranged for translation.
Also if you could
maybe talk a little bit
about how you [inaudible].
>> Dawit Gebremichael
Habte: Got it.
If I understand you correctly,
one is how did I write it
in my native language
and get it translated.
>> Right. Or did you write
part of it in English?
>> Dawit Gebremichael Habte: Or
did I write it part in English
and part in my native language?
The second part is how did I --
What is the process
that I followed
for publishing the book.
For the first one, I
actually wrote the book
from the beginning
to end in English.
English is my kids' language.
The first language I spoke
is my mother tongue Tigrinya.
In school, we were
forced to learn Amharic.
So we're taught using Amharic.
Once I arrived in Kenya,
survival forced me
to learn Kiswahili.
And then came to the US.
So the option was either Spanish
or English and I chose English.
So I will explain
part of the process.
For Bloomberg, my responsibility
is to manage the dev-ops,
developmental operations team.
And one of the principles
of dev-ops is fail fast.
And I failed actually
badly at the beginning
when I had my first book
draft ready in 2005.
I sent it to publishers in 2006.
I was rejected by
more than 26 of them.
And one of them gave
me good advice.
He called me to his office.
He said he doesn't remember it
because he's is the president
of the company that
published the book.
So the idea he gave me was that
I should go write an article
to one of the New
York publications
and then an editor
might pick it up
and then they might interview me
so that they could
ghostwrite the book for me.
It's a fair -- I took
it as fair feedback
because he's the only one
who actually took his time
to give me that feedback.
And the message I received I
took from that conversation was
that I have a good story
but my writing sucked.
No way around it.
So Professor Tekie Fessehatzion,
who was the chairman
of the economics department
at Morgan, I relayed to him,
I told him the feedback that
I received and he suggested
that I read about 15 books.
So went back, started reading,
and started writing online.
And one of the best books that
I read that seriously helped me
with this book is titled the
"Kaffir Boy," by Mark Mathabane,
if I am not mistaken,
South African.
He has done an amazing job in
terms of capturing the life
of apartheid and how he
survived as a young man
and then how he came
to the United States.
So I kept reading, writing,
reading, and writing.
Finally, a miracle happened.
A lot of people -- Well, I moved
to New Jersey, I mean to --
I'm kind of in tears
because it's a miracle
that I can't say any, I can't
describe it in any other way.
I moved to Virginia and I got
hired by a company called BNA
for three-month contract.
Well, six years later --
Actually five years later,
Mike Bloomberg bought
the company.
I had quit his company, moved
here, and he bought the company.
And the new vice-president came.
I was talking to him
and I told him, listen,
I have a great relationship
with the Bloomberg company.
Mike has done this for me.
I've also drafted a book.
So here it is.
I gave him the draft.
The story that I heard
after that is I think
about four months later this guy
was flying back from New York.
He sent me an email saying,
Dawit, I need to talk to you.
I have some interesting
to talk to you.
And I said, okay.
I wanted until four.
He didn't come.
It was late.
So the next day I
walked to his desk
and I said, what's going on.
And his name is Joe Breda.
He's now the president
of B. Law, Bloomberg Law.
He grabs me -- We
went to his office
and he said Mike Bloomberg
was talking about you.
I said I haven't talked to this
guy for more than seven years.
How did he end up
talking about me.
Joe Breda said that he was
presenting to Mike Bloomberg
and his senior management team
and apparently Joe
Breda forget a datapoint
that he couldn't remember.
So Mike was trying to make
him feel at ease and he said,
listen, I remember
everything from my childhood.
How can you, you know, he was
trying to make him feel at ease
and in the middle he said,
except I forgot this guy's name.
There was one guy.
We gave him money.
He went to Eritrea but
couldn't remember his name.
And Joe Breda told him, I
know who you're talking about.
He's like, no, you don't.
How can you know, you
just joined the company?
He said his name is Dawit Habte.
He said, yes.
Where is he?
He's like, he's working for you
through BNA and he has written,
he has drafted a book you
may be interested in reading.
And Breda told me he was
going to send my name to Mike.
I said don't do it.
I will send him a thank
you note and I said, Mike,
thank you so much for
remembering because we all live
in each other's memory.
And that is the most
precious place we all have.
And if this guy could put my
name somehow in his [inaudible]
by not remembering
it, and he said,
well I'll stop by
when I come to DC.
Stop by when you
come to New York.
Listen, you are paying
for my flight.
You are paying for the hotel.
So I might as well
go and say hi.
And that is how -- So I can
only take credit for writing it.
The rest is so much
positive coincidence
that is completely
outside of my control.
And as you probably would
realize reading the book,
most of my life is outside
of my control, a lot of --
The only thing that I might
have done right is I hold
on to people.
I hold on to friendship.
I don't let it go.
Yes, sir?
[ Inaudible Audience Question ]
Yes. I think if I understand you
correctly you are asking me have
I taken into account the
publications and books written
by Eritreans who are
professional historians.
>> Have you been fair with
the history of [inaudible]?
>> Dawit Gebremichael
Habte: There is no dispute
when it comes to the
history of Eritrea.
In fact, I intentionally avoided
mentioning them in my book
and I'll tell you why.
Because I am Eritrean.
I am presenting the Eritrean
view and I have a responsibility
to show publications and
historical references
that are written
by non-Eritreans.
What is that?
[ Inaudible Audience Comment ]
No, no. I'm agreeing with you.
I'm not arguing with you.
I'm not arguing any of them.
[ Inaudible Audience Comment ]
Okay. Okay, let me
try to elaborate
and then you can correct me.
The side of history that I have
presented is the human cost,
the human cost.
What I'm saying is
Eritreans have paid day in,
day out for decisions that are
made without their consultation.
And this goes back, it
doesn't start in 1950s.
I just gave a reference.
It goes back to the Italians.
It goes back to the
building of Suez Canal.
Once Suez Canal was built,
the Pandora's box
opened in that area.
Eritrea literally became
a pawn in the chess game
between the East and the
West and people suffered.
Their survival was
a simple mechanism
of taking care of each other.
That is the whole point I've
tried to make in this book.
Fair enough?
>> Let's give a chance
to others.
We were discussing --
>> Dawit Gebremichael
Habte: Hi, Helen.
Yes?
[ Inaudible Audience Question ]
Yes. Helen is asking me I have
spoken about what the book is.
Can I also elaborate or speak
about what the book is not.
The book is not your typical
memoire in that majority
of the memoires that are
written for self-promotion.
I have done this.
They become a resume of the
individual who is trying
to accomplish something.
My accomplishment is simply
to tell the human history
of Eritrea and also the humanity
that I encountered
throughout the short life
that I have lived so far.
So it is not self-aggrandizing.
That's why it's called
"Gratitude in Low Voices."
It's not self-promotion and I
may take credit for doing C,
but A, B and D are
done by someone else.
Most of it completely
outside of my control.
So it's not -- And it's
not an autobiography.
The gentleman, he
mentioned a few books.
All those books that
he mentioned are
actually autobiographies.
They are not memoires.
Memoire has a timeframe.
It describes an event, a time
and it's not from the beginning
of life to end of life of
somebody's accomplishments.
What it is not?
Yes, it is an inspiration
because I wrote it
because I needed inspiration.
So you might read about my
experience in the refugee camp
and some nights walking through
the forest of southern part
of Ethiopia which I have never
been before that but it's not
for you to feel --
It doesn't portray
for someone to feel
sorry for me.
It basically gives a perspective
and actually it's presented
in such a way that might
have made me who I am.
Thank you.
>> Any more comments, questions?
>> From someone who has a
short memory, I'm wondering
if this book was part
of a diary or journal.
Did you j[inaudible] that
when you were growing up?
How do you go back and
remember names the way you did
in the book [inaudible]?
But for you, how do you
remember [inaudible]?
>> Dawit Gebremichael
Habte: Thank you.
Sophie [assumed spelling]
is asking me how the book is
so detailed, how did you
remember the details in terms
of places, names, and events?
Were you taking notes?
Do you have some kind of diary?
I did take notes.
The day that I left
home for some reason --
We have this calendar it's
called [foreign word].
It's a small calendar.
I left home with that calendar.
So starting from the 5:00 a.m.
we went to the airport to fly
to [inaudible] and we didn't
catch the morning flight.
So we had to take the
evening, the 6:00 pm flight.
Starting from that, going
through the southern part
of Ethiopia, the
forest and Kenya,
through all that life I
was actually taking notes.
That [foreign word] I still have
it and amazingly the benefit
of that [foreign word]
was it completely took me
out of my physical presence.
Every time I went from my --
There were about seven of us.
I went from the group
and started writing.
I was going away from the --
I basically I was transforming
mentally to a different place.
So that made all the
suffering nonexistent.
And one of our colleagues
actually did tell me that,
Dawit, why you even bother
to write this nonsense?
Aren't we're going
to die anyway?
Why bother?
And my answer was
simply so what.
I will be dying writing.
So what's the point.
In terms of remembering
my childhood,
especially my childhood
activities
and the treasure is I'm
extremely fortunate.
I have people like
Daniel sitting right here.
We got lost when we were
six or seven years old
in the city of Asmara.
So I have many of them and we
meet every day, every weekend,
every month, every Saturday we
have a get together for Gejeret
and what I did was after I wrote
it, I doubled checked with them
and they gave me feedback
where yes, this is accurate.
You may have missed this.
That number you are wrong
because they give me names.
So I was able to
get that information
from my childhood friends.
For the other personal stories
of the people, I actually went
and interviewed all of them.
Mebrahtu Negusse, [inaudible]
who was my angel who came
from heaven to actually,
until six years old,
until six grader -- Until I was
in sixth grade, I didn't know
to use dictionary and
until I met that guy,
his children showed me how
to use dictionary and how
to even they even showed
me what a library was.
For him, I knew he
came to Boston.
So I went, I drove there.
We spent three days
and nights interviewing
and then getting all
the facts that I needed.
And after I wrote it,
I sent it back to him
when we back to Eritrea.
He reviewed so I did go back --
I did interview a lot of people
because again, this is personal
story and it has to be accurate
and it has to have
proper context.
>> Maybe one more.
[ Inaudible Audience Question ]
>> Dawit Gebremichael
Habte: Yes.
You are asking me to give
some context to the title
and also describe to you why
"Gratitude in Low Voices."
>> Yeah, I like the title.
I like the title of the book.
I'm not sure what
you meant by it.
>> Dawit Gebremichael
Habte: Yes.
Okay. It actually
came from the book
and I am trying --
Yes, on page 36.
Usually when I came home from
school with my test results,
mom would say, "Son, how
did you do this time?"
From her tone, I could easily
tell that she was concerned.
Mom would start searching
from sticks marked with x
in red pen on my exam papers.
At times she would count two or
three x marks out of 20 or 30.
Once she finished
counting the x marks,
she would straighten her head
and say, "Son, what happened?
Were you sleeping in class?"
No, [foreign word],"
I would respond.
[foreign word] is my mom.
"Look, I got seven correct,"
I would protest while
selectively placing my finger
on the questions I
answered correctly.
"Of course," mom would say,
"why else would you
go to school then?
I don't think you
understand my question.
I'm asking you if
you were asleep
in class half of the time.
Otherwise, how could
you miss this many?
But [foreign word], the others
got a lot more wrong than me.
This is a good grade,"
I would protest.
"Those are not kids,
son," my mom would say.
Our exchange would continue
with my mom pulling me close
to her for a warm hug.
This time though, this is when
I brought an award from school.
I was first from my first
grade so I brought an award.
So this is the time.
"This time though mom's tone was
more of excitement and elation.
Grace be upon all you saints
for delivering my prayers
to our father in heaven.
Thank you, Saint Mary, for
watching over my family.
Thank you, [inaudible],
for this day.
The gratitude of my mother would
continue in low voices for me
to hear until tears starting
wailing up in my mom's eyes.
Mom then looked at me with
a big smile somewhat trying
to hide her emotions.
Mom's low voice and her broad
smile were the most powerful
expressions of love and
compassion no amount
of words could express.
That's where the gratitude
in low voices came from.
Thank you so much.
[ Applause ]